what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as we pick up with exo-m at a
war we basically jump in to pre Lu two
armored hunters and this is actually
really really cool and one of the things
I like about this is it really kind of
just like hits home with the traditional
fare of exilim and we're content coming
out of a and that's what makes it so
cool because I mean this is Robert
Venditti writing this and so we're going
to keep in mind is that rubber band
idiot he's not the new guy like he's not
new to color books from ended he knows
how to write comics he knows how to
write characters he knows how to tell
stories and the same thing goes with
that Ian I mean valiant in the 1990s it
was Marvel DC valiant and even right now
in terms of shared continuities it's
Marvel DC valiant they're kind of like
the top three color book publishers at
the moment so because of that what we
give a textual amount of war is a return
to familiarity and what I mean by that
is with dying as a whole it's usually
like you know the world outside your
window that kind of thing so if one day
you know if you open your window one day
and it was a man flying around in a
spaceship it would probably be EXO Man
O'War Italy definitely they try to tell
the story and the cool thing about this
is that it takes that very concept that
we've seen for the first you know 20
some-odd issues or something like that
you know we've seen so far and it rolls
it over into expanding the mythos the
reason why is because it's necessary to
do that it's necessary to introduce a
character tell stories that give you an
understanding of what that character is
about their rise in terms of power where
they are when they have that power and
their fall from power and how they cope
with it after that is okay let's expand
that whole thing and that's one of the
cool things about this story is because
it follows the Captain America path you
know we fought during world war ii who
was frozen for 20 years who was thought
out and then led the avengers with Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern he was a Green
Lantern for years and years and years he
fell from grace became a bad guy he
basically died came back to life or at
least that seemed to be the case anyway
became the spectre you know that kind of
thing but anyway went back to being a
Green Lantern again so it's just the
cycle of being a hero having power
falling from being a hero and then
coping with that change and so what this
does is it actually picks up out in
space and it deals with the Chinese
space station now for the other half of
this is that remember following the
events of unity it was the formation of
a team designed to take down EXO Manowar
because of the fact that he himself had
intended to invade romania and restore
Visigoth a country that had long since
been destroyed you know someone or 1500
2000 years prior so because of that the
goal was to basically find a way to
subvert him and then bring him under the
fold of you know the US military now
keep in mind the u.s.
he's not doing this because they
genuinely want him to have a place to
stay nobody any standard a measurement
that military's doing this because they
want to weaponize the exo-armor
and if they can't duplicate the armor
they might as well have control the guy
who uses it and so there's kind of a
give-and-take here you know XO Man O'War
and as people are freed from captivity
and allowed to basically live in their
own village and they're off you know day
to day while they're monitored by the
military but they're off limits to
virtually everybody else in exchange
exilim an award carries out missions for
the US military so because of this the
tasking of this group as it monitors in
the military extraterrestrial recon
outposts also known as Miro
actually basically gets wind of a some
kind of an attack or some kind of an
incident that took place out here in
Chinese astronauts or so but XO tasks to
go and investigate we basically have
some being that resembles EXO man awards
terms of his armors appearance laying
waste to all video this entire Chinese
space station now again this is cool
because the first question is who is
this guy and why does his armor look
like EXO's armor why does it look like
half the armor and my first thought
about this was that maybe he was a
failed experiment
maybe he's a person that tried to
utilize the armor before he didn't pass
through you know whatever test the armor
uses and was only able to use a fraction
of it or you know sort of it bonded to
him he didn't die from the experience
but whatever the case may be the cool
thing about this is that right off the
bat it's casualties of course that's one
of the great things about valiant is
necessarily kill people but they show
collateral damage and that's something
you don't really see that often in like
Marvel Comics you don't really see an
instance where two super villains are
fighting a building collapses and like
all 200 people inside died you see that
in DC but you don't really see that too
much in Marvel comics but the offset
they give and take is that you see a lot
more diversity in terms of the different
kinds of powers the different kinds of
groups and so on and so forth DC keeps
things you know relatively close normal
Mesa so groups like really the x-men a
lot more prominent whereas DC's Doom
Patrol is more of a nitch kind of thing
that makes any sense hopefully I'm not
hopeful that's make it so see you guys
but with X no matter war here again it's
really just kind of investigating and
figuring out what's going on but in the
fight between himself and this guy he's
basically thrown through this Space
Station and some of the guys are killed
when they're sucked out so again it's
not the most important thing ever but it
does go to show you the valiant doesn't
really shy away from the idea that
individuals die as a result of these
heroes now valiant doesn't do this for
the sake of just let's show people being
killed they do it because what it does
is it creates consequence it shows you
that when superheroes fight
supervillains there's consequence for
those actions that people are killed in
the crossfire and that's the big
difference here it's very easy if they
would just show us a building that
explodes it's like what man not building
crashed you don't really see the people
inside you don't see the reaction and so
the connection isn't there but when you
see a guy being sucked out of an airlock
in EXO Man O'War Erik trying to hold on
to this guy's arm for dear life only for
the armor to be ripped off and they got
to be sucked out due to the pressures of
oxygen escaping the facility then
there's consequence then it's like well
he couldn't save that guy he tried his
best and he couldn't save him and so
again it's really kind of cool to see
those scenarios unfold but the funny
thing about this is that this guy's it's
fighting XML a war it's fighting out of
desperation but it almost seems like
legitimate bad guy the other half of
this if he keeps making reference to
like individuals who are coming after
the armored individuals who are coming
after him individuals who are looking to
capture the armor for themselves now the
reason why this is a big deal is because
one of the most important things that
Robert Van Diddy has established so far
with the exosuit is that it can't be
used by just anyone the exosuit goes
through a selection process that people
who put it on if they fail the test will
die now we don't know exactly why they
died we should just know they're not
worthy they're not gamed worthy by the
armor for whatever reason excellent man
award has been deemed worthy and he's
able to use it but this was basically
the standard fare for his individual
character with the introduction of these
guys who were armor hunters what it
tells us is that where this exo-armor
was seemed to be nigh unstoppable and
completely overpowered really it needed
a nerf what's basically being revealed
here is there are beings out there who
work in will of taking down exo-armor so
again it really kind of asked the
question who are these guys and where's
their power coming from now in terms of
the conflict between the two it's pretty
straightforward I mean it's pretty
point-blank in terms of how they're
going against one another I mean it's
really just the idea that EXO is fitting
off as best he can this guy has the
ability to regenerate himself whenever
he's injured and so the indication here
seems to be that his entire body is
impacted by the armor instead of just
whatever sections the armor is covering
so it still works for the purpose that
it serves but it also makes this guy a
very formidable asset and the reason why
is because this dude basically says look
I'm experienced in fighting against
other people with the same kind of armor
that I have me this individuals for
people who have
armored at the same time he's also
skilled in just fighting in general and
so it really kind of provides Eric with
a with a worthy combatant a guy who
actually gets the better of Eric and is
on the verge of killing and now again
the EXO armor is just as much a part of
Eric as it is a part of itself meaning
the axonal armor can operate
independently of Eric and that's exactly
what happens here in the sense that when
this guy goes to kill EXO the armor
reacts and basically knock this guy out
now again at this point we just kind of
jump back to mirror the question being
what was it that EXO found the other
half of this is this sets the stage for
like our Marines it sets the stage for
the actual main armor hunter story
because now what's been established here
is there's more than one exosuit and so
what this means for the u.s. military is
that if there is more than one exosuit
that they can find a way to basically
harness the exosuit that the suit is not
contextual strictly to one person that
there is not one suit out there and you
know Eric is the only one that has it it
means that anybody can wield it so at
this point it's a matter of cracking the
code it's a matter of finding out why it
is that some people can use the suit and
some people can't but again what we end
up doing here is we actually jump to a
foreign planet called planet planet
better planet Bakke I'd love to think
that is planet back because I loved back
back in the day that would be awesome a
new planet back a BEC where all they do
is just play back to like a planet where
they just play back music all the time
that would be amazing but we basically
have a guy who's been killed a guy who's
gone in this exo-armor who's been
eliminated so again this is a pretty
formidable group in the sense of they're
tracking down individuals who have EXO
suits and killing them so again they're
able to overpower the armor which make
these guys pretty significant moreso
than that some of them one of them seems
to be composed of what seems to be pure
energy at other ones composed of what
seems to be a rocky alloy again it's
people hailing from different locations
presumably just differ graces all
throughout the cosmos whether they're
artificial or you know organic what we
end up doing is finding out this guy
this leader is named primary and primary
is essentially traveling across the
universe for reasons unknown for the
intention of tracking down all these
different people who are really the
exo-armor killing them and then assuming
you know presumably taking their suits
as trophies so again we don't really
know exactly what's going on here this
actually gets followed up in the main
armor hunter story but it's a pretty
cool free loot I mean it really sets the
stage and ask the question is Eric the
only one who could reel the exo-armor if
he's not
and what potential this humanity have to
wield this virtually non-stop it will
soon that presents that provides its
user with all sorts of powers but if you
guys are new here to come let's explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the Rob cork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah not bad for a two-part
story and I will catch you guys on it
peace
[Music]